at a house oversight hearing committee
today investigating the hunter Biden
scandal the second IRS whistleblower
revealed himself to the public for the
first time and coming forward I believe
I'm risking my career my reputation and
my casework outside of the investigation
we are here to discuss I've recently
discovered that people are saying that I
must be more credible because I'm a
Democrat who happens to be married to a
man I'm no more credible than this man
sitting next to me
due to my actual due to my sexual
orientation or my political beliefs the
truth is my credibility comes today from
my job experience with the IRS although
I do have my supporters others have said
that I am a traitor to the Democratic
party and that I am causing more
division in our society
no wonder why the Democrats did their
very best to change the subject back to
their favorite distraction Donald Trump
the real criminal and the actual threat
to our Democratic institutions is Donald
Trump I would welcome also a hearing on
the former president's history of tax
evasion and how long it took to see his
tax returns we are here today
because Donald Trump is exerting an
influence campaign
in Congress we is no longer president to
the United States
she actually thinks Americans are that
stupid to disregard what they saw with
their own eyes and heard with their own
ears
but in this case it was the men behind
the curtain and they were articulate
credible and steadfast now after hearing
him speak for hours we all come to the
obvious conclusion
someone way up in doj maybe the
assistant U.S attorney Leslie wolf at
the direction of the Attorney General
himself
was protecting Hunter Biden United
States Attorney Weiss told us that he
was not the deciding person that he had
requested and was denied special
Authority after D.C declined charges and
that if California declines you will
have to request special authorities
again I understood the gravity of those
admissions
yeah because if Hunter was treated like
anyone else with the same set of damning
facts he'd be going to jail it wouldn't
be on probation and that of course would
hurt President Biden politically
so oh yes we learned a lot today despite
Democrats really anemic attempts to
distract us we got some clarity on the
key question that I've been asking for
months
how did the Biden family get so rich
approximate total transfers from the
Romania company would have been 3.1
million to everyone how much did Hunter
Biden is business associates received
from State energy HK limited through the
Robinson Walker LLC 3 million the total
transfers from Hudson West 3 to everyone
was 3.7 million Prisma paid to everyone
involved 6.5 million barisma also paid
Blue Star Strategies in a law firm
hundreds of thousands of dollars
bringing the total barisma payments to
over 7 million dollars is is that
correct that is correct 7.3 million
between 2014 and 2019 this brings the
total amount of foreign income streams
received to approximately 17 million
dollars correct that is correct
17 million dollars man and I thought
Hunter Biden was just an expert in doing
eight balls of coke off the stomachs of
prostitutes
he must be really smart to be paid 17
million dollars by all these foreign
businesses while Daddy was in office
now look anyone who claims to be a
political reporter in this town in
Washington who didn't watch this hearing
or didn't report on it and I mean really
report on it should turn in his or her
press credentials same for anyone who
claims to care about democracy but
aren't bothered At All by the fact that
the bidens put our government up for
sale
a bunch of journalistic frauds
the justice department allowed the
president's political point to use a
weigh in on whether to charge the
president's son I watch United States
Attorney wise to a room full of senior
FBI and IRS senior leaders through that
he was not the deciding person and
whether charges were filed
the entire day Mr shapley and Ziegler
laid out all the disturbing facts as the
special agent on this case I thought the
felony charges were well supported in
early August of 2022 Federal prosecutors
from the Department of Justice tax
division drafted a 99-page memorandum
they were recommending for approval
felony and misdemeanor charges that did
not happen here and I am not sure why
well we all know why to protect the
president
it's as clear as day that someone higher
up in the doj stepped in for the Biden
assist and that the U.S attorney in
Delaware did not have the final say in
this matter
now the few times that the Democrats
tried to lay a glove on the
whistleblowers ended in epic fails like
when one goofy Congressman tried to
dismiss the question of political timing
but couldn't even get his exhibits right
he said at page 23 and I remember there
were always times
where we were always on an impending
election cycle I don't see where you
referenced it in my Tran you know from
page 23. you're talking about how the
election cycle is delaying decisions I'm
sorry sir that's in special agent
Ziegler's transcript that's why I
couldn't find it
whoops let's try that again
Mr Ziegler and you shared concerns about
delays related to the election cycle but
at that time Joe Biden was not the
president
I believe at that time he was the
nominee for president so I'm confused by
a line of questioning we're talking
about an election to which uh now
President Biden was a part of so he
didn't have to be the president to have
election meddling no but the question is
this was he the president at that time
in April 2020. it's been asked and
answered answer is yes or no is no that
thank you thank you I reeled back Mr
chairman may I finish
uh please you may answer the question so
you know it's clear that he was not the
president but an election is for the
purpose of electing a president and and
Joe Biden at the time was a nominee
this is just embarrassing it was another
liberal swing in a mess and the
left-wing whiffs kept coming
it seems to me that a lot of your
testimony has been about the problem of
prosecutorial discretion and the
traditional tug of war between
investigators and prosecutors who are
more attuned to the rigors of the
courtroom it wasn't just investigators
that would agreed with these charges in
exhibit two in the in my testimony it
clearly shows a prosecution
recommendation report where it says
right in the document the the uh the the
assistant United States attorneys and
Department Justice tax division agreed
with those uh recommended charges
uh can I buy a vowel well look what the
bidens have done here what the doj did
to save the president's son it's just
more evidence of how little any of them
care about America the rule of law or
frankly our International reputation
because now every foreign country every
foreign ambassador everyone knows that
the U.S government is up for sale
except maybe the Americans who rely on
the regime media to tell them the truth
because the other networks didn't even
cover this hearing a passing mention
it's not important
because for them the only thing that
matters is preventing Trump or anyone
like him from ever being elected again
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else